it's a strong performance by the bank um
5.1 billion of operating profit and it's
a combination of obviously the
continuing delivery of our strategy and
the strong support of our customers we
saw 6.7 increase in lending growth you
know really importantly we stayed in the
mortgage market during the period of
disruption we're continuing to lend to
business responsibly so uh delivery of
strategy good performance and most
importantly a strong resilient balance
sheet which means we can continue to
support our customers through what Still
Remains challenging macroeconomic
conditions you've set aside 337 million
pounds for for doubtful loans that's
lower than the market was expecting why
is that
now we're not seeing any signs of stress
on our balance sheet I think you know I
would distinguish between the real high
anxiety and concern that customers are
feeling from the cost of living squeeze
and I think you know for businesses it's
it's really tough out there when I when
I talk to businesses up and down the
country they're really struggling but
incredibly resilient but what we're not
seeing is that move into arrears in
mortgages for examples or defaults on
loans or what we call heightened
monitoring on our business loans in fact
our levels remain pre-covered free covid
levels so that gives you a sense of how
resilient the UK economy and households
and businesses are being but it is
really tough out there we're making sure
that we're providing and keeping our
balance sheet with lots of capital and
lots of liquidity so we can deploy it to
help people and stand alongside them
what kind of assumptions are you making
about the trajectory of bank rate this
year
yeah on our assumptions um going forward
we've assumed interest rates stay at
four percent for the rest of the year
and then gradually reduce over the
course of next year so that those are
the assumptions that we're making and
then we're working really hard with you
know businesses and families to think
about how we can help them navigate both
sides of their balance sheet whether
it's lending and savings to support them
obviously the Market's been spooked by
your outlook statements on net interest
margin this year I assume that is
underpinned by your expectations are on
bank rate which is slightly more dovish
than the market as a whole is is
thinking
yeah our guidance we're very thoughtful
when we give guidance to the market I
mean we're essentially saying we expect
to make a return on tangible Equity of
between 14 to 16 I've always talked
about making sure the bank is delivering
long-term sustainable returns good
Capital so that we can support our
customers and support the economy
um we've made an assumption of four
percent I think the latest forecasts are
that that may be higher but I think it's
important that we are able to deliver
what we say and we're quite thoughtful
about the guidance we give I think 14 to
16 return on tangible Equity will
probably be the best guidance that is
out there in the market importantly we
have liquidity and capital to support
the economy obviously you've come under
Fire recently for the extent of the
interest rate rises from the bank of
England that you're passing on to Savers
why are you not being more generous as
it were
well what we're doing is we're making
sure we're really targeting helping
people save and one in four people in
this country have less than 100 pounds
of savings in their account so one of
the strategies I put in place when I
took over was how do we help build
Financial resilience our digital regular
saver account is paying six percent
interest and that's helping people build
the habit of saving you can save as
little as as one pound but that six
percent means it's encouraging people to
save our Roundup tool we have over a
million people using that now on a
regular basis and we've helped 1.7
million people save a hundred pounds for
the first time and so that's about
building Financial resilience so six
percent on our digital regular saver we
have fixed term deposit accounts paying
between three and four percent so I
think we're we're paying good interest
rates we have a suite of products but
what I'm really focused on is how can we
help build resilience and particularly
in young people as well our youth
account is paying two percent and we're
doing a lot of work helping young people
build Financial skills and capability
ability where post covered and in the
cost of living we're seeing real lack of
confidence in the younger generation
eighty percent of them are not confident
about their financial capability and 57
are saying cost of living is the thing
that they worry about most so we are
passing on interest rates we're
targeting it around building healthy and
sensible savings habits rewarding it
with six percent interest rate you
mentioned just now that you stayed in
the mortgage market during the upheaval
of the Autumn what kind of assumptions
are you making about the housing market
this year
yeah it was really important we stayed
in the mortgage market during that
period of disruption it was hugely
stressful for customers we were one of
the only banks who stayed in the market
we didn't pull products
um what we are seeing with higher
interest rates that there are lower
volumes in the mortgage Market as as you
would understand
um and so the bank of England I think
put out some data around
um smaller volumes in the mortgage
Market what we're focused on are
customers largely are on fixed rates
around 90 to 93 percent of our customers
have fixed rate so we're really working
with them to say how do we help you
navigate what are the choices that you
have going forward we are seeing
mortgage rates come down closer to four
percent now and I think that's a real
positive for um households in terms of
house prices
um you know we are seeing a softening
in-house price our economic assumptions
are house prices may drop by around
seven percent I think the obr says 10
don't forget house prices Rose by 10
over the last year so
um though you know there is some
softness in that market the most
important thing is helping customers
think about what's the right choice for
them now you've increased the size of
the bonus pool by 70 million pounds to
367 and a half million pounds your pay
has gone up from 3.6 million to just
over 5 million pounds is that
appropriate during a cost of living
crisis
well the bonus awards that we've paid
are really reflective of of the
performance and and NatWest has always
been a back marker on bonuses and I
expect us to continue
um to do so I think in terms of
um our award for our colleagues we've
really focused on those on the lowest
salaries as well for my own pay clearly
in the financial services sector it's in
incredibly
um an incredible privilege to do these
jobs and we're very well rewarded and
I'm very cognizant of that but you
weren't tempted to to waive any bonuses
in in view of the the sort of
difficulties that a lot of customers are
going through right now
well I think it's important that we
continue to deliver strong financial
performance and and reward our
colleagues for the job they're doing as
I say our bonus pool is significantly
lower than the rest of the market we
always tend to be a back pair on that
and making sure that we we balance that
appropriately and retain good talent
within the organization